you are one of my parenting icons
oh parenting icon oh i love you i love
being a mother though drew you must you
must too
i loved i loved every single stage and
still do
still do you wrote something um in
your book that made me burst into tears
this morning
um maybe you would choose to concentrate
on how to manage life's big
relationships imagine being able to send
that word
that marriage gets complicated and that
sometimes the decision to stick it out
or to leave
is the best one you will make in life
it's true i think
i think the hardest decision i've ever
had to make in my life and ever will
was that choice because i too wanted
that perfect family
that four top for life the double date
um and so to have the opposite
experience for my children
than i had and it was as if i made the
ultimate promise
of my life and i wasn't keeping it
um and it was the hardest decision
i've ever made in my life you know back
in the day
people would stay together for the sake
of the children but what messages does
that
send to the children that you should be
miserable and stay in a relationship i
think everybody deserves to be happy
look this is what i realized
as long as kids feel loved and secure
they will be okay
and as long as they know that they have
the both of you and they don't have to
choose sides
that's the thing you you never want them
to feel they have to choose sides or if
they love their dad it's a sight against
you or vice versa
they will really be okay
[Music]